Hey guys, this is Emily.
And today, we're gonna talk about tipping in America.
Do you know what tipping is?
I bet you don't.
Maybe you do.
But tipping is when you pay money to someone who has done a service for you,...
...such as a waiter, a waitress, a hot bartender,...
...a person at Starbucks, a taxi driver, et cetera, et cetera.
But you have to pay these people because their salaries are really low.
Unlike in Japan, where you just get ripped off with the table charge occasionally.
But yeah, you're supposed to pay the person 20% of what they gave you.
So, they sold you pasta for ten dollars, give them a two-dollar tip...
...or more if you're feeling super generous.
I don't know, I'm bad with math.
That was never what I was good at in school, I failed twice, I think.
Anyway, if you don't tip your waiter or waitress,...
...it means that either the service was really bad or you're a jerk.
No one likes to be a jerk.
I know I don't.
But I mean, sometimes when your service is really bad or you've had a rough day...
...or you're in a bad mood, it's okay not to tip.
But just be prepared, because the person that you've gypped on the tip might come after you...
...with a pocket knife or pepper spray.
Because everyone has weapons, all the time.
It's like "Street Fighter", only you're not in the street, you're in America.
Maybe on the street in America.
So if you go to America, tip a guy and tell him, "Have a nice day!"...
...because everyone likes to feel good about themselves.
I'm sure you do.
Anyway, this has been Emily, telling you about tipping in America.
See you next time!